صدر الحكم باعدام الطالب اسلام محمد فتحي
بعد ادانته بقتل زميلته في الجامعه
الطالبه سلمى بهجت مع سبق الاصرار والترصد
في جريمه ارتكبت على مرمى حجر من هذه
المحكمه
منع التصوير في قاعه المحكمه وسط اجراءات
امنيه مشدده في محيطها ورضا من قبل اهالي
الضحيه عن الحكم رغم علمهم بنيه المدان
نقد الحكم طبعا هم في طاعن طبعا دي
اجراءات قانونيه لازم تمشي ودو ضد اسطوري
بتاعنا يقدمه الطعن بتاعها وده عادي
لان ديت لازم تجرارات قانونيه في الدستور
المصري عايزه سلمى ان شاء الله بامر الله
بعد ما يتنفس حكم الاعدام على الاسلام
والد المحكوم عليه بالاعدام حاول بعد رفع
الجلسه رؤيه ابنيه لطمئنته لناحيه الخطوات
القادمه وتقدمه بنقد الحكم خلال 60 يوما
من تاريخه ده واحد مريض نفسي ولهم ملف في
الصحه النفسيه ازاي ياخذ اعدام مفيش الشرع
الحكم صدر بعد اربع جلسات فقط بدات في
سبتمبر الماضي قبل ان يستقر في عقيده
المحكمه ان المتهمه لا يعاني من مرض
النفسي وانه مسؤول عن افعاله طبقا للتقرير
الطبي تامر نصره العربيه الزقازيق